[Music]
on this Thursday night the exhausting
battle against Nova scotia's Relentless
wildfires the punishing conditions for
Crews the reinforcements on the way and
the Hope parade our fingers across that
we're going to receive that
precipitation
the shortfalls in Sharing intelligence
about foreign meddling what Canada's
national security advisor says needs to
change
as pride month begins Uganda stands firm
on its harsh anti-gay laws let's
remember that not all of us are free
what this means for Ugandan Refugee
claimants in Canada
and the Art of self-acceptance I've got
to come to grips with who I am one
Japanese Canadian painter's journey to
embracing his family's history
global national with Donna Friesen
good evening and thanks for joining us
we begin tonight in Nova Scotia help is
on the way to fight the fires that
continue to threaten communities and it
Force thousands of people from their
homes Crews from other provinces the
United States and as far away as Costa
Rica are coming and the Canadian
military is being dispatched to help
relieve exhausted Nova Scotia Crews yet
some people in The Province according to
the mayor of Halifax are still
contributing to the problem
believe it or not in the last 12 hours
we have had somebody burning leaves with
a propane torch we've had somebody else
who was starting a bonfire this is a
clear violation of the no stupid policy
if ever there is one and I think
everybody can understand that don't do
it
16 fires are burning in Nova Scotia four
of them are out of control hot dry
weather plus gusting winds are making
fighting them harder Mike Armstrong is
in Upper 10 Talent near Halifax
done it with multiple fires across the
province there's sort of an expression
we've been hearing from firefighters
over and over today we are stretched but
holding
so we're welcome and warranted breaks
for firefighters working the tantalon
fire extreme heat made this a grueling
day with the humidity temperatures felt
like 35 degrees Celsius to that the fire
fighting gear what some call ironically
their snow suit the Heat and wind also
worsens wildfires there's rain in the
forecast and there's hope that it comes
our fingers across that we're going to
uh to receive that precipitation and
help us a little bit we need to we need
mother nature to get on side with us on
this
one thing that's worked in the favor of
firefighters is the topography the
Lakes helicopters are able to reload
easily and quickly we're turning about
20 to 30 drops an hour wherever there's
a fire we're no more than three four
hundred meters away from from doing the
drop
now the tentelon fire is 50 contained
enough that one area had its evacuation
order lifted Wednesday night I'm gonna
put it in the house the whites moved
back in this morning after four
stressful days our daughter was was
actually having a baby as well so he was
in the neonatal unit our house was
potentially going to burn down it was a
tough tough time
at the Southwest end of Nova Scotia the
evacuation orders are still growing two
fires continue to burn out of control 50
homes have been destroyed the region is
more sparsely populated but the fires
having a major impact our municipality
you know we probably lost probably
almost 50 percent of our employees
because they've been directly affected
they've got to evacuate their house and
their families there has been
frustration for Nova scotia's Premier
about ottawa's reaction this week these
conditions this early in the season are
unprecedented the federal government
Thursday promised new Resources by the
morning there should be military
personnel and Equipment starting to
arrive to relieve firefighters
Mike Armstrong Global News Halifax
this early start to the fire season is
worrying according to the federal
government's Canadian drought monitor as
of April 34 percent of the country was
classified as being in moderate to
severe drought including 61 percent of
the country's agricultural areas and
Atlantic Canada neighboring New
Brunswick is battling its own set of
early wildfires and a much larger swath
of the region is expected to remain
under abnormally dry conditions in the
coming weeks including parts of
Newfoundland and a chunk of Labrador
some areas in New Brunswick Nova Scotia
and Pei shown in Orange are already
considered to be in a moderate drought
further west the situation is even more
alarming an early and explosive Wildfire
season is well underway and parts of
Saskatchewan Alberta and BC shown here
in brown are already in severe drought
conditions the abnormally dry weather is
expected to spread well into the
Northwest Territories and stretch East
into Manitoba and parts of Ontario
Global News meteorologist Anthony
Farnell is with me Anthony what's ahead
in the forecast
Donna definitely a glimmer of hope and
for many much more than that a complete
change in the weather pattern is coming
all of the record temperatures and
droughty conditions being replaced by
cool air and a lot of rainfall today was
the hottest of the entire week 35
degrees in Fredericton and miramashi
Montreal
Ottawa Toronto all Breaking Daily
records for June 1st but we are also
tracking a cold front as it moves in
there is the risk of thunderstorms we
don't want lightning strikes where it's
been so dry but we definitely need the
beneficial rain and there will be a lot
of that as we go into Friday and
especially this weekend scattered
showers turns into a widespread rain
across Nova Scotia and that rain will
continue right through early next week
local amounts of 30 to 80 millimeters
which is going to do a great job not
just containing these fires but likely
putting them out when it combines with
the cooler than normal temperatures
Donna
Global News meteorologist Anthony
Farnell thanks
[Music]
here's one measure of how dry it is in
Alberta this land spout tornado was
spotted near stetler yesterday it picked
up huge amounts of dirt and dust and
state over Open Fields though and no
damage was reported
there was a Frank admission today from
the top National Security advisor to the
Prime Minister Jody Thomas says there
have been breakdowns in the way
intelligence reports are handled by the
government she's testifying at a House
of Commons committee looking into
allegations the Chinese government has
been targeting members of parliament
Eric Sorensen reports on what she said
and whether anything's been fixed
The Briefing from ceases confirmed to me
at least three MPS former conservative
leader Aaron O'Toole conservative MP
Michael Chong and new democrat Jenny
Kwan have now been told they were
targets of foreign interference but top
officials in government say they did not
know the Prime Minister was not made
aware Jody Thomas the National Security
and intelligence advisor to the Prime
Minister The crucial Point person
between National Intelligence and the
country's top political leadership said
her predecessors did not tell the PM and
he only learned of it after recent leaks
to the media I cannot account for
um
the lack of information flow to the
Prime Minister and the prime minister's
office and I'm not going to speculate
I agree that there needs to be a better
management of intelligence Thomas says
she missed one memo while on vacation a
breakdown in communication that she says
is being improved Bill Blair when he was
minister of Public Safety also pleaded
ignorance to intelligence that he says
the director of cesus did not share with
him quite clearly if they determine that
information is not required to be to be
shared with us and I have no knowledge
of that I I would not have the
opportunity to act on it the
conservatives critic on the procedure
and house Affairs committee suggested
that the Prime Minister either was
briefed or should have been how is it
but prime minister didn't know why were
those MPS cap of dark and in the face of
all of that would you not at least
concede but that is a colossal breakdown
of the Machinery of government under
this prime minister's watch Jody Thomas
says while ceases is constrained from
sharing sensitive intelligence there
needs to be more transparency with the
Canadian public and with MPS who will
now be told when they are targets even
if the Intel isn't deemed credible there
is absolutely a risk to transparency
uh there is a greater risk to not
talking about foreign interference next
week the special repertoire David
Johnston will be questioned at the
committee about his report on foreign
interference but likely will be pressed
to end his part in the investigation
after a majority of MPS voted that he
stepped aside Eric Sorensen Global News
Toronto
the U.S is denouncing what it calls an
aggressive move by China over the South
China Sea the U.S military says a
Chinese jet flew dangerously close to
this American aircraft last week the
Chinese have been increasing their
military presence in the disputed region
Canada's hmcs Montreal is there too as
part of operation projection to promote
peace and stability our Mackenzie gray
is on board and tonight he gives us a
rare bird's eye view of the mission
85 000 boats travel through the South
China Sea every year but hmcs Montreal
is on the hunt for just one we were made
aware of a Chinese dredging vessel that
is in the area that is reportedly
dredging on top of HMS Prince of Wales
record site HMS Prince of Wales a
British ship sunk by Japanese Torpedoes
in 1941 killing 327 on board the Chinese
boat allegedly willing to disturb those
Graves for a shot at second world war
memorabilia
to find it the Cyclone helicopter on
board the Montreal has been dispatched
we're not here to escalate any tensions
we're here to be a reporting asset and
just a forward presence for the Navy
but after over an hour's worth of flying
no luck an unsuccessful Mission with a
positive twist we weren't able to to
locate them today which is good because
it means they weren't in the vicinity of
the uh the records that they were
suspectedly pillaging the search one of
the numerous flights to Montreal Cyclone
undertakes while at Sea and we were
lucky enough to join them for one
from the air a beautiful view of the
ship it's over 30 years old but it's
undergone extensive renovations to
upgrade many of the systems I know it
sounds loud but it's a surprisingly
smooth ride here on this Cyclone which
helps give the Montreal forward presence
and can conduct anti-submarine Warfare
that versatility making one of The
Montreal's most valuable assets we're
always looking to see sort of who's in
the area who's on the surface who else
is up in the air but before a ride is up
one last assignment
hoisting me down to the flight deck a
maneuver normally used to ensure a quick
exit performed perfectly by the crew
as for the Chinese ship it was detained
by Malaysian authorities the day after
the Montreal went looking for it and on
board Donna scrap metal and cannonballs
believed to be from HMS Prince of Wales
okay Mackenzie gray on the South China
Sea thanks a teenage girl is facing
criminal charges after fireworks went
off inside a Toronto Transit bus
the 14 year old who cannot be identified
has been charged with Mischief
endangering life no one was hurt when
the fireworks were set off inside that
bus but it was filled to capacity the
Toronto Transit Commission says there
have been at least seven incidents in 10
days involving fireworks on Transit
vehicles
running for safety in Kiev coming up
reports and air raid shelter was locked
as people tried to escape Russian
missiles
[Music]
Ukraine is being accused of shelling a
Russian Border Town using soviet-era
Rockets a residential low-rise building
caught fire and a neighboring
administration building was also damaged
there were no reported injuries and
Ukraine denies any involvement
President Vladimir zielinski has renewed
calls for his country and others
bordering Russia to join NATO and the
European union he was speaking to
European leaders in Moldova today and
said without membership there is either
open war or occupation Ukraine was
pounded again today with a barrage of
Russian missiles in the capital three
people were killed including a child
because the shelter they ran to was
locked Crystal gemancing Reports even
when missiles and drones fired at
Ukraine are shot down there's no
escaping the possibility of death this
man now faces unspeakable tragedy under
the foil blanket lies the body of his
nine-year-old granddaughter according to
those at the scene it appears the three
victims including the child's mother and
another woman were hit by Falling debris
they were trying to get into a shelter
that was locked you show the worst
people and the question they was before
and or after I came say yes or no I can
give you clear answer for that in this
station give the answer for that the
mayor of Kiev has ordered all public
shelters be checked to ensure they're
accessible while he was at the site
another siren every day this week the
capital has come under attack from
Russian airstrikes here in moldovan
luckily we don't hear year rate sirens
or the town of Russian Artillery just 20
kilometers from the Ukrainian border and
the war the European political Community
gathered for its second Summit with
security as the main topic Vladimir
zielinski called for Ukraine to be
admitted to Nato this year although
there's no sign that will happen
back in key families laid flowers and
toys where the nine-year-old was killed
June 1st is children's protection day in
Ukraine but parents confessed to feeling
powerless in the face of Relentless
missile and drone strikes
he sat in the corner of our Corridor he
cried saying that we're all going to die
I was terrified to hear this from him
since the full-scale invasion zielinski
says at least
484 children have been killed by Russian
aggression
Global News London
restricting rights ahead while being
openly gay in Uganda could now mean the
death penalty
[Applause]
today marks the start of Pride
celebrations across Canada in many parts
of the world though gay and trans people
have no rights and some places being
openly gay is a crime
Uganda has just passed some of the
harshest anti-gay laws in the world and
the president there says he will not
reverse them despite widespread
condemnation Global News has learned
those laws will affect how some Ugandan
Refugee claims are assessed here in
Canada Redmond Shannon explains
as soon as uganda's President signed the
new anti-gay Bill human rights lawyers
filed a challenge made a statements that
showed that she was in favor of passing
this law and yet I speak it's supposed
to be basically impartial opponents also
complained that not one lgbtq2 person
was consulted by lawmakers same-sex
relationships were already illegal in
Uganda the new law includes the death
penalty for same-sex transmission of HIV
deliberate or otherwise and for serial
offenders against anti-gay laws
Uganda joins 11 other countries where
homosexuality is or could be punishable
by death many members of uganda's lgbtq2
community believe that getting out is
the only option they have left you are
arresting us for literally doing nothing
for simply existing
you know but where are we supposed to
how did we become refugees in our own
countries immigration refugees and
citizenship Canada told global news that
the new law in Uganda means some
ugandans who have been refused A Refugee
claim in the past year may now be able
to reapply for a pre-removal risk
assessment before returning to Uganda
the sailing is finished nobody will move
US uganda's president is defiant as
Washington threatens visa restrictions
for Ugandan officials and Aid Cuts if
they interfere with our trade we shall
trade with others
prime minister Justin Trudeau called
uganda's law appalling and abhorrent
Global Affairs Canada says it will work
with Partners in the region to support
persecuted communities activists from
Uganda ask that those who struggle for
the most basic of Rights not be
forgotten this pride month as everyone
is out there celebrating let's remember
that not all of us are free freedoms
most of us take take for granted remain
denied to Millions just for being who
they are Redmond Shannon Global News
London
[Music]
between next to Japanese Canadian
artist's journey to honor his heritage
[Music]
there was a period in this country when
Japanese Canadians were considered enemy
aliens stripped of their property and
forced to move many into internment
camps that was during the second world
war and it shaped the lives of future
Generations well now a legendary
Japanese Canadian artist is exploring
his history through a retrospective of
his work turia Israel looks at the work
and life of Norman Takeuchi
Norman takayuchi has been an artist for
60 years but in some ways considers
himself a late bloomer at some point I
thought you know I've got to come
through grips with who I am his life's
work is on display at the Ottawa art
gallery a retrospective spanning decades
and a rediscovery of his identity from
early on I like a lot of people My
Generation felt
certain amount of shame in my earlier
work there's absolutely no indication at
all of my ethnic background takayuchi
was born in Vancouver in 1937 to
Japanese Canadian parents when he was
just four years old he and his family
were forcibly removed from their homes
the Canadian government sent more than
20 000 Japanese Canadians to internment
camps during the second world war my
family was one of the so-called
self-supporting families and rather than
send us to a camp but uh we were sent to
a small community in the middle BC like
a lot of the other families they lost
everything his parents rebuilt their
lives and paved the way for takayuchi to
follow his passion as a graphic designer
how old are you in this picture I was
about
27. his big break came at Expo 67 in
Montreal and then expo 70 in Osaka he
also found success as a painter but it
took 30 years before takayuchi began
incorporating his culture in his work
Catherine knows more about me
the representation of his dual Heritage
is featured in the new exhibit entitled
shapes in between
Catherine Sinclair is the curator she
helped choose the name by asking
takayuchi a question well where do we
find you Norman and he responded
something to the effect of well I'm in
the shapes in between and that just felt
like a very poetic way of of
understanding where he finds himself to
learn about history that we should know
about that we don't it's really a
wonderful opportunity at 85 he only now
feels like he's made it it wasn't until
this exhibition that I started to feel
well maybe
I'm doing some good work after all he
says that good work was only possible
because of the support of his wife of 57
years Marion six Decades of love art and
self-discovery teria isri Global News
Ottawa